lord deliver them
from the deceptive forces
that seek to distract them
from your redemptive wisdom
do not leave or forsake us
for you are the hope
for our tomorrows
we pray in your merciful name
amen amen
please join me in reciting the pledge of
allegiance to the flag
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one nation
under god indivisible with liberty
and justice for all
the clerk will read a communication to
the senate
washington dc may 27 2021 to the senate
under the provisions of rule one
paragraph three of the standing rules of
the senate
i hereby appoint the honorable jackie
rosen a senator from the state of nevada
to perform the duties of the chair sign
patrick j leahey president pre-tempore
this
mmm
[Music]
[Music]
five
so
so
[Music]
foreign
um
[Music]
[Music]
so
now
[Music]
go
good
madam president the majority leader
well the senate opens this morning after
a very late night of amendment votes on
the us innovation
and competition accusinka that's the
initials
we're starting to call it that five in
total
four of which of these amendments were
sponsored by republicans
so far on this bill the senate has held
votes on no fewer than 18 amendments
four from democrats and 14 from
republicans and there are more to come
as i mentioned yesterday in a landmark
moment for bipartisanship in the senate
we even adopted an amendment from
senator rand paul by
voice vote yes that's right i said the
two words together
rand paul voice vote four words
but i said the two concepts together
rand paul voice vote four words now
the media will tell you that if you're
talking process you're losing
but the process was really important
here for years
senators have been clamoring for a more
open process and more amendment votes
i can't tell you how many speeches i've
heard on the floor about the virtues of
regular order
well this competition bill ought to be
the answer to my colleagues prayers
the bill has moved through regular order
flying through various senate committees
with staggering bipartisan votes
the entire senate opted to take up the
bill by a vote of 86 to 11.
and here on the floor we've held the
kind of vigorous bipartisan
open amendment process that senators
have been calling for
some of these votes were tough for our
side in the old days we would have said
no
we said yes we'll vote for them but
let's keep moving forward
and we are listen to this it's only may
roughly five months since democrats took
the majority in this chamber and already
more amendments have received roll call
votes
than during any any of the past four
years
let me repeat that so people hear it
from one end of the capitol to the other
particularly on this side of the aisle
in five months
more amendments have received roll call
votes in this democratic-led senate
than during any of the years in which
donald trump was president
and senator mcconnell was majority
leader
we have considered the competition bill
in an exceedingly bipartisan way
there'll be a few final steps to take a
few final amendments to consider
but i hope my republican colleagues have
seen our commitment to developing
drafting and perfecting this legislation
in total concert with the other side of
the aisle
with cooperation from our republican
colleagues we can finish the bill today
and i hope we do that's our intention
because because despite the lack of
attention it has garnered from the press
the u.s innovation and competition act
will be one of the most significant
pieces of bipartisan legislation we pass
in a very long time it could be a moment
in history
that future generations look back on as
a turning point
for american leadership in the 20th
century 21st century
everyone knows the federal government's
commitment to science and technology has
been slipping for decades
we've been complacent at the top of the
global heap
and our position as the world's economic
leader is teetering
we now spend less than one percent less
than one percent of our gdp
on basic scientific research the chinese
communist party as a percentage spends
more than twice that
we put ourselves in a very precarious
position
of potentially falling behind the rest
of the world in technologies
and industries that will define the next
century
if that happens the days of america
leading the world
in scientific innovation the days of
america being the leading economic and
military power in the world may be over
this is a moment when the united states
senate can arrest the decline
and lay the foundation instead for
another
american century that's why this is a
moment
in history that future generations could
well look back on as a turning point
for american leadership in the 21st
century
by investing in science and technology
shoring up critical industries
like semiconductors boosting our
universities laboratories and businesses
we can keep america on top and out
compete the world in industries of the
future
that is just what this legislation would
do
our two parties have worked very hard on
it i think we've made a number of
notable improvements to the bill
it's time to move forward together and
pass this bill
now on another matter that should also
be just as bipartisan in the senate
the commission to investigate the
january sixth attack on the capital
we all know that january 6 was one of
the lowest moments in our democracy one
of the lowest moments in the grand
grand history of our 200 and some odd
year
experiment noble experiment in democracy
an outgoing president of the united
states fresh off an electoral defeat a
significant electoral defeat
did something that no other president in
recent history
has done rather than accept the results
of the election
and support the peaceful transfer of
power
a hallmark of our democracy that has
inspired democracies all over the world
former president trump unabashedly lied
repeatedly about the results of the
election
and fomented an armed rebellion and
armed rebellion
at the united states capital we're all
witnesses to those events
we all heard the lies we lived through
the terrible consequences
lest we forget 140 police officers were
injured in the attack
five americans would eventually lose
their lives
in the weeks since faith in our
elections has plummeted
more than half of the republican party
now believes
that 2020 elections were rigged and that
joe biden isn't the actual president of
the united states
republican state legislatures across the
country captured by donald trump's big
lie
are tripping over themselves to restrict
access to the ballot box
arizona republicans in quote unquote an
election
audit have been researching for traces
of bamboo fibers in the 2020 ballots
chasing a banana bananas crazy
right-wing internet conspiracy
that china had ballots imported to tip
the scales for biden
that is how insane this has become
hunting
for bamboo in ballots
we need to put a stop to this cancer in
the republican party
we need to stand up to the big lie we
must get at the truth and do everything
in our power to restore americans faith
in our elections
and this grand ongoing noble experiment
of democracy
in that light a national bipartisan
independent commission to report on the
events of january sixth is exactly what
the doctor ordered
we have to investigate expose and report
on the truth
we need to establish a trusted record of
what really transpired on january the
sixth
and the events that preceded it that's
what this commission is designed to do
in a bipartisan straight down the middle
manner
now i've gone through all the silly
excuses that we've heard from our
republican colleagues
about why the commission isn't needed
it's too early will go on for too long
needs to be modeled after the 911
commission even though it already is
the truth of the matter seems to be that
senate republicans oppose the commission
because they fear that it might upset
donald trump and their party's midterm
messaging
i'm not speculating that was reported in
politico yesterday that the senate
leader
republican leader warned his conference
that january the sixth commission could
hurt the republicans politically
well too bad this is too important
for the sake of americans faith in our
democracy there must be a full
thorough and trusted account of what
happened on january the 6th
senate republicans must decide if
they're on the side of truth
or on the side of donald trump's big lie
i yield the floor and note the absence
of a quorum
or i re asked unanimous consent that the
quorum i just noted
be dispensed with so noted
and now i ask unanimous consent that the
senate proceed to executive session
to consider the following nomination
calendar 135
that the nomination be confirmed the
motion to reconsider be considered made
and laid upon the table with no
intervening action or debate
that no further motions be in order to
the nomination that the president be
immediately notified of the senate's
action
and that the senate then resume
legislative session
without objection now madam president
i now note the absence of the choir the
clerk will call the role
ms baldwin
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
great
without objection from coast to coast
american families are facing
an explosion of violent crime on their
streets and in their neighborhoods
2020 saw homicides skyrocket nationwide
the sharpest one-year increase in
decades
and 2021 is already shaping up
to be even worse last year seattle
saw a 61 percent increase
in murders citywide in 2020
minneapolis saw homicides hit levels not
seen
since the 1990s and so far 2021
is about doubling last year's pace
here in washington 2020 saw homicides
hit a 16-year high
and again 2021 is already on an even
worse
trajectory the situation is devolving
all across the country in my hometown of
louisville as one report put it quote
the number of slayings in 2020 dwarfed
anything louisville has seen
obliterating obliterating the previous
record
crime and delinquency have many causes
in some ways
the pandemic likely contributed
but it's impossible to ignore that these
terrible trends are coming precisely
as so-called progressives have decided
it's time to denounce
and defund local law enforcement
seattle for example cut police funding
by 20 percent
minneapolis defunded cops by millions of
dollars
the district of columbus city council
approved 15
million dollars in cuts
these bone-headed decisions are the
direct result
of any law enforcement fed that has
swept through the political left
like a wildfire and perhaps just as
important as these funding cuts is the
wave of hostile sentiment
that comes with them harvard scholars
have found that after high
profile incidents reduce the trust
that the public and politicians put in
the police the cities in question
received less active policing
and subsequently see an increase in
crime including
homicides in other words in the wake of
terrible incidents like we saw last
summer
local leaders should look for ways to
build bridges and rebuild trust between
the vast majority of brave and honorable
officers
and their communities oh no but instead
what they do
from city councils to the halls of
congress many on the far left decided to
crank the knob
all the way up on anti-cop rhetoric
all across the board quote
not only do we need to disinvest from
police but we need to completely
dismantle the minneapolis
police department quote policing in our
country is inherently and
intentionally racist no more policing
incarceration
and militarization incredulous people
asked whether this nonsense was ever
meant
seriously helpfully one member of
congress clarified
quote defunding police means defunding
police
end quote a clarifying comment
a small set of politicians may see
selfish opportunities for fame
or fundraising if they defame and define
the police
but american families are paying a
deadly price
defunding the police isn't just a
terrible idea for overall public safety
it's also a uniquely awful strategy for
racial justice
one study recently confirmed that quote
larger police forces save lives and the
lives saved are disproportionately
black lives so look i'm not sure exactly
how the rantings of the far left twitter
about crime and policing became
official democratic party dogma in so
many places
across america what i do know is that
ordinary americans cannot bear much
more of this and that goes double for
the most
vulnerable neighborhoods
now madam president on another matter
last week the senate took up sweeping
legislation it touches on big issues
that span many committees from economic
policy to national security to
scientific research
and beyond 86 senators voted to proceed
to this debate
me included that wasn't because the
legislation was
ready to go it happened because there's
broad bipartisan agreement that america
needs to upgrade our competitiveness
with china broad agreement that this
subject deserved a robust debate
and amendment process since then we
voted on
some amendments but as of this moment
the senate's bipartisan work
is simply not completed the democratic
leader indicated that if the chairman
and ranking members worked together
if committees put their heads together
their work would get consideration
out here on the floor well chairman
wyden and ranking member krepo the
finance committee have
a bipartisan provision that's ready to
go
they've already done the hard work
they've reached a solution
but thus far the democratic leader has
refused to include it in his substitute
and has not
allowed the senate to vote on it
separately
these are long-term issues we're
considering
we need to get this right and during the
time this legislation had been on the
floor we've had
entire days come and go without any
votes
at all on the bill in several instances
the democratic leader chose to pivot
away from this legislation and devote
floor time
to nominations so there's no excuse for
shutting off debate prematurely before
the senate's been able
to have its say so we'll have to see how
today unfolds with additional amendments
the democratic leader lets the senate
consider how open a process
he permits republicans don't want some
big fight over this
we'd like to see an outcome a bipartisan
outcome even now discussions are
continuing
behind the scenes but the democratic
leader should not try to force a cloture
vote prematurely
to stifle the senate before members are
satisfied
that our work is finished there's
nothing unusual about a minority party
denying closure to secure more amendment
votes
i've been here a while this happened all
the time
six years ago even after about two dozen
amendment votes
democrats blocked cloture on a keystone
pipeline bill until the senate took a
dozen more amendment votes
on top of that just last year even as
the economy was tanking around us the
democratic leader blocked cloture
multiple times
on the cares act emergency legislation
why he wanted more changes
but i hope it doesn't come to that today
i hope the democratic leader lets the
senate be the senate
so we can finish this important
legislation
now one final matter as my colleagues
know i've been clear and unflinching
in my own statements about january the
6th
but as i've also repeated there's no new
fact about that day
we need the democrats extraneous
commission to uncover
the department of justice is deep into a
massive
criminal investigation 440 plus
people have already been arrested
hundreds
hundreds have been charged even more
arrests are said to be planned
and the attorney general indicates this
investigation
will remain a top focus multiple senate
committees are conducting their own
bipartisan inquiries
and obviously the role of the former
president has already been litigated
exhaustively exhaustively in the
high-profile
impeachment trial we had right here in
the senate several months ago
i do not believe the additional
extraneous commission
that democratic leaders want would
uncover crucial new facts
or promote healing frankly i do not
believe it is even designed to do that
that's why the speaker's first draft
began with a laughably rigged and
partisan starting point
and while the current language would
still lock in significant unfairness
under the hood so i'll continue to
support the real
serious work of our criminal justice
system
in our own senate committees and i'll
continue to urge my colleagues to oppose
this extraneous layer
when the time comes for the senate to
vote
under the previous order the leadership
time is reserved
morning business is closed under the
previous order
the senate will resume consideration of
s 1260 which the clerk will report
calendar number 58 is 1260 a bill to
establish
a new directorate for technology and
innovation in the national science
foundation and so forth and for other
purposes
i suggest absolutely the clerk will call
the role
ms baldwin
[Music]
[Music]
hello
[Music]
here
you
so
[Music]
uh uh
madam president the republican bad
president is a senator in quorum call
yes i ask you unanimous consent that the
quorum call be lifted
without objection and a president from
the beginning
the story of the u.s auto industry has
been one of ingenuity
of taking risks and of pushing forward
at the dawn of the 20th century most
americans could
hardly comprehend the idea
of the automobile yet 20 years later
they had become nearly ubiquitous
in american life thanks to the
insistence of entrepreneurs
like henry ford on making the automobile
affordable for the majority
of americans the democratization
of the automobile rather than the
invention of the automobile itself is
in my opinion one of the most remarkable
and uniquely
american success stories automobiles
allowed americans to capitalize on the
economic dynamism
of the roaring twenties and helped
americans move and adapt
during the great depression they
contributed greatly
to the american industrial base and the
know-how needed to fight and win the
second world
war and help propel the united states to
its current status as a preeminent
global
economic and military power
visionary investments like the
interstate highway system made cars a
staple
in american economic and cultural life
and cars
certainly made it a lot easier to get to
and from
rural america in a place like rural
south dakota with limited public
transportation the automobile
often a pickup or an suv is typically
the only way to get around mr president
today the automobile industry stands on
the brink
of a new technological revolution which
promises to dramatically transform
mobility once again over the past three
decades the internet has transformed our
economy and our way of life
and the next generation of the internet
5g which is currently being deployed
across the nation
will enable a host of new innovations
including a revolution in vehicle
technology
automated vehicles or what we call avs
avs will change the way that we move in
numerous ways making the transportation
system safer more efficient
and more accessible individuals whose
mobility is currently limited for
example americans with disabilities
could gain new independence with the
deployment of automated vehicles
allowing them to work or visit friends
and family
safely and easily
i'm proud that my proposed av amendment
to the endless frontier act was recently
endorsed
by the national federation of the blind
and i ask for unanimous consent that the
letter of endorsement be inserted
in the record without objection
or imagine a farmer in rural south
dakota
who can no longer drive to get to town
for appointments prescriptions or
groceries
enter the automated vehicle this
technology has potential to keep people
in their homes and communities longer
moreover avs have the potential to
greatly increase
roadway safety currently there are
an average of more than 35 000
traffic fatalities on our nation's
roadways each year
including pedestrian motorcycle and
bicycle fatalities
automated vehicles could dramatically
dramatically madam president reduce that
number
distracted driving driving while
impaired
automated vehicles could eliminate those
dangers
madam president for automated vehicle
technology to advance it is imperative
that the regulatory framework catch up
with private sector innovation
that's why i've pushed for the enactment
of av legislation over the past several
years and why i had hoped
i had hoped that we'd be voting to add
my automated vehicles amendment to the
legislation before the senate today
i've spent nearly five years
five years madam president working in a
bipartisan manner on a legislative
framework to govern the testing and
deployment
of automated vehicles the amendment i
offered to the bill before us today an
amendment that i had hoped to be able to
offer with bipartisan support
would have paved the way for expanded
testing
and deployment of automated vehicles in
the united states under the oversight
of the national highway traffic safety
administration
and let me emphasize that over say
oversight
point my amendment would ensure that
automated vehicles
would not not touch
pavement without the national highway
traffic safety administration
certification that they
are at least as safe as a conventional
vehicle
the data gathered from the vehicles
deployed as a result of this amendment
would be crucial to the development of
future motor vehicle safety standards
for avs
unfortunately bipartisan agreement on my
amendment collapsed
when special interests express their
opposition
despite major efforts to accommodate
their concerns and i am deeply
disappointed
that once again democrats yielded the
pressure from special interests
against the best interests of our
economy and the american people
advancing av technology is not just
a vehicle safety issue it's also an
issue of u.s leadership and global
competitiveness
investing in the production of av
technology here in the united states
would not only strengthen the resilience
of the auto industry
but also the nation's industrial base
and
and our national security the auto
industry touches
nearly every american state
for example horton in britain south
dakota
manufactures engine cooling systems
providing steady good-paying jobs for
that community
and strengthening the local economy the
same story repeats itself countless
times in
communities all across the nation
providing millions of jobs and investing
billions annually the american auto
industry is a critical
critical component of the nation's
economy
right now u.s companies lead the world
in av technology but other nations like
china
are seizing upon regulatory inaction and
striving to take the lead
if we don't move forward with automated
vehicle technology we will soon see
some other nation leading
the av revolution madam president the
legislative package before us today is
designed to bolster the global
competitiveness of the united states
it is pretty difficult to understand
why this reasonable
and i might add no cost
av amendment which would lead to untold
benefits
for our nation's transportation system
does not fit in
how can a bill making strong investments
in artificial intelligence quantum
computing and advanced manufacturing
exclude a legislative framework
for avs are we really
going to back down from leading the
world in automotive
innovation and technology and see the
future of this industry of this industry
i should say
to nations like china will we really
ignore the enormous
enormous safety benefits of these
vehicles just to suit
democrats political convenience
madam president more than a century ago
when the automobile was invented there
were plenty of skeptics
but america's automobile pioneers
did not let that stop them
they seized the moment and pressed
forward and ushered in
a transportation revolution
we can do that again today or
or we concede this moment to nations
like china
and let the american automobile industry
fall permanently behind
that's the choice in front of us madam
president
i hope we'll choose to seize this moment
and pass the legislation we need to
usher in another
american transportation revolution
i yield the floor and i suggest the
absence of quorum
the clerk will call the roll ms baldwin
[Music]
so
this
[Music]
so
ah
uh
[Music]
me
thank
look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
very
hmm
[Music]
oh
yes senator from illinois
without objection
by unanimous consent oh sorry the clerk
will report the motion to
invoke cloture cloture motion we the
undersigned senators in accordance with
the provisions of rule 22 of the
standing rules of the senate
do hereby move to bring to a close the
debate on schumer substitute amendment
number 1502 to calendar number 58
s 1260 a bill to establish a new
directorate for technology and
innovation in the national science
foundation
to establish a regional technology hub
program to require a strategy and report
on economic security science research
innovation manufacturing and job
creation to establish a critical supply
chain resiliency program and for other
purposes
signed by 17 senators by unanimous
consent the mandatory quorum call has
been waived the question is
is it the sense of the senate that
debate on amendment number
1502 offered by the senator from new
york mr schumer
to s-1260 built to establish a new
directorate for technology and
innovation
in the national science foundation to
establish a regional technology hub
program to require a strategy and report
on economic security science
research innovation manufacturing and
job creation to establish a critical
supply chain resiliency program and for
other purposes
shall be brought to a close the yeas and
nays are mandatory under the rule the
clerk will call the roll
ms baldwin mr barrasso
bennett mrs blackburn
mr blumenthal mr blunt
mr booker mr bozeman
mr braun mr brown
mr burr ms cantwell
mrs capito mr cardin mr carper
mr casey mr cassidy
ms collins
coons mr cornyn miss cortes masto
mr cotton mr cramer mr crapo
mr cruz mr daines miss duckworth
[Music]
mr durbin ms ernst
mrs feinstein mrs fisher
mrs gillibrand mr graham
mr grassley mr hagerty
[Music]
miss hassan
mr hawley
mr heinrich mr hickenlooper
ms hirono
mr hoeven
mrs hyde smith mr inhofe
mr johnson mr kane
mr kelly mr kennedy
mr king miss klobuchar
mr lankford
mr leahy mr lee
mr lujan miss lummus
mr mansion mr markey
mr marshall mr mcconnell
mr menendez mr merkley
mr moran ms murkowski
mr murphy mrs murray
mr ossoff mr padilla
paul mr peters
mr portman mr reed
mr rish mr romney
ms rosen mr rounds
mr rubio mr sanders
mr sass mr schatz
mr schumer mr scott of florida
mr scott of south carolina mrs shaheen
mr shelby miss cinema
miss smith miss stabenow
mr sullivan mr tester
mr thune mr tillis
mr toomey mr tuberville
mr van hollen mr warner
mr warnock ms warren
mr whitehouse mr wicker
mr wyden mr young
[Music]
so
mr barrasso voted in the negative
[Music]
mrs murray mrs murray hi
mrs fisher mrs fisher no
okay
you
mr cassidy mr cassidy i
[Music]
this
my
[Music]
yes
[Music]
mr van hollen mr van hollen
me
mr scott mr scott of florida no
mr romney mr romney
mr heinrich mr heinrich aye mr merkley
mr merkley
aye hey
mr cardin mr cardin aye
oh
um
mr bennett mr bennett i
mr tubberville mr tuberville no
mr shelby mr shelby no
mr tester mr tester
so
mr peters mr peters i
[Music]
ms baldwin ms baldwin i
miss shaheen mrs shaheen aye
mr kelly mr kelly
[Music]
mr johnson mr johnson no
mr reed mr reed
mr casey mr casey i
mr warner mr warner i
[Music]
mr wyden mr wyden aye
[Music]
is
mr inhofe mr inhofe no
miss lumis miss lummus no
mr marshall mr marshall no
mr sanders mr sanders
[Music]
no
mr kane mr kane aye
mr sullivan mr sullivan no
mr murphy mr murphy i
mr hoeven mr hoeven no
mr cotton mr cotton no
mr lujan mr lujan i
mr brown mr brown i
[Music]
mr mansion mr mansion
good
mr menendez mr menendez
[Music]
mr twomey mr twomey no
miss klobuchar miss klobuchar hi
mr durbin mr durbin
[Music]
so
[Music]
mr markey mr marky
miss smith miss smith hi mr leahy mr
leahy
aye mr cruz mr cruz no
mr lee mr lee no mr hawley mr hawley
no mrs feinstein
mrs feinstein i
miss hassan miss hassan i
mr rubio mr rubio no mr padilla mr
padilla
aye mr ossoff mr ossoff i mr booker mr
booker
i
this mr king mr king
i
mr rounds mr rounds no
mr coons mr coons
well
ms rosen miss rosen
mr white house mr white house
ms warren miss warren i
mr sass mr sass no
kramer mr kramer no
mr kennedy mr kennedy no
mr cornyn mr cornyn no
foreign is cortez masto miss cortez
masto
[Music]
mr paul mr paul no
[Music]
mr carper mr carper i
miss murkowski miss murkowski aye
mr warnock mr warnock aye
do
so
mrs gillebrand mrs gillibrand
[Music]
mr haggerty mr haggerty no
mr hickenlooper mr hickenlooper
mr blumenthal mr blumenthal
robbie
so
food
mr rono miss hirono i
[Music]
you
foreign
this
do
so
foreign
oh
maybe
so
so
[Music]
all right let's go
yes
i'm